beginnen wir inhaltlich und herr gassen
beginnt ja vielen dank sehr geehrte
damen und herren der winter steht nicht
völlig überraschend vor der tür und auch
nicht völlig überraschend steigen die
infektionszahlen wieder
das gibt natürlich durchaus anlass zur
sorge es schon mehr als sorge aber uns
geht es heute darum
hinein aussagen die wir trotzdem gut
durch den winter kommen denn wir haben
im vergleich zum vorjahr doch einige
veränderte rahmenbedingungen
viele dinge die wir im letzten winter
nicht hatten haben wir heute es gibt
kein mangel mehr in schutzausrüstung der
wissen vielmehr über das virus und vor
allen dingen wir haben wirksame
impfstoffe in ausreichender menge und
nicht zu vergessen wir haben
zehntausende impfzentrum das ganze land
verteilt nämlich die niedergelassenen
praxen der kolleginnen und kollegen und
wenn jetzt und das ist ein aktuelles
thema die booster impfung gemäß den
empfehlungen der ständigen
impfkommission
durchgeführt werden sollen dann ist das
eine aufgabe diese praxen leisten können
die werden die auch leisten entscheidend
dafür ist aber dass das ganze in einer
gewissen etwas ruhigeren und geordneten
atmosphäre funktioniert die praxen
können da enorm ist weiß das haben sie
eine vergangene gewesen bis zu 300
millionen impfungen die woche dafür
müssen die rahmenbedingungen stimmen und
jetzt stehen natürlich die
auffrischimpfung im vordergrund wir
haben zwar auch noch einen gewissen teil
der verfolgung der noch nicht geimpft
ist leider zu einem gewissen teil auch
offensichtlich da nicht von einer
impfung zu überzeugen ist aber wir
müssen einfach sehen wie kommen wir
jetzt mit diesem anspruch an die booster
impfung klar wir sehen das seit die
stiko empfehlung aus ist die zahl der
bestellenden kolleginnen und kollegen
wieder angestiegen ist auf über 30.000
die impfstoff dosen bestellt werden
steigen bereits wieder an und über zwei
millionen haben bereits eine booster
impfung bekommen das ist regional sehr
unterschiedlich beispiel ein sehr sehr
gut damit ein booster impfquote von rund
90% andere bundesländer ging dann ein
bisschen hinterher wir reden über rund
15 millionen menschen die bis ende
dezember ihre booster impfung bekommen
sollten dafür wäre es zum beispiel gut
und hilfreich wenn die in einem
geordneten einladungsverfahren auch
erfahren würden dass sie jetzt zur
zielgruppe der booster impfung und
erinnert es manchmal auch manchen dran
wenn immer wieder davon abweichende
empfehlung eben nicht ärztlicher
provenienz kommen die dann bevölkerung
verunsichern abläufe in praxen auch
kritisieren zum teil und insgesamt das
ganze eher bremsen als beschleuniger
also das ist machbar wir können dass die
rahmenbedingungen müssen stimmen und
politik hilft uns an dem punkt
tatsächlich am besten wenn diese
rahmenbedingungen halt geschaffen werden
und die regel nicht alle paar wochen
geändert werden und für uns für die
nächsten ärzte ist halt die entscheidung
und die empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission die auf die wir uns
verlassen die basiert auf
wissenschaftlicher datenanalyse und
abweichende empfehlungen wie gut gemeint
sie auch immer sein mögen verwirren
daher und einige verlässliche regeln die
ich kurz skizzieren möchte auch wenn
jetzt die epidemische lager nationaler
tragweite auslaufen soll was ja nur ein
regelwerk darstellt gibt es überhaupt
keinen grund warum man diese regel nicht
an anderer stelle verlängern kann und
auch sollte das ist beispiel die
verlängerung der korona impfverordnung
das ist die kone test verordnung
und ganz wichtig praktische und banal
erscheinende dinge wir brauchen eine
kurzfristige bestellmöglichkeit viele
praxen das sind momentan 14 tage das ist
nicht gerade förderlich um schnell
reagieren zu können und wir müssen
glaube ich anerkennen und auch hier wer
uns eine klare ansage der politik sehr
wichtig da die impfstoffe immer noch in
größeren teils kommen das wissen sie und
das wird auch sich kurzfristig nicht
ändern weil die produktionsstätten nicht
so schnell umgestellt werden können wir
also keine einzeldosen haben brauchen
wir ein klares bekenntnis der politik
dazu dass die kolleginnen kollegen auch
wenn sie diese weise nicht vollständig
aufbrauchen trotzdem impfen können und
die verwerfung der impfstoffe in einer
gewissen form zu regeln ist die aber
klar kommuniziert sein muss sonst gibt
es hier wieder probleme weil dann die
menschen natürlich erst mal gesammelt
werden müssen damit sie entsprechend
hier auch die impfdosen nicht verwerfen
ist und deshalb glaube ich wir haben
viele instrumente in der hand dass wir
gut und sicher durch den winter kommen
und damit möchte ich erstmal bewenden
lassen dass sie hin wir machen bei herrn
mertens weiter ja vielen dank frau
wollte also sie wissen das ja nun
hinlänglich was die aufgabe der stiko
ist es tico muss
der gesetzlichen auflagen die sie hat
evidenzbasierte empfehlungen für
deutschland erarbeiten und das bedeutet
sowohl für das individuum in deutschland
als auch für die gemeinschaft hier und
daran haben wir uns bisher
ausschließlich gehalten auch wenn es
natürlich anders lauten und berichtet
gibt aber wir haben uns wirklich aus die
sich daran gehalten wir haben uns von
niemandem beeinflussen lassen in unserer
entscheidung und wir werden das auch
künftig nicht tun nun es gibt
durchbruchs infektionen das haben sie
auch alle jetzt hinlegen nicht gehört
und es entsteht einige aufregung darüber
wenn man das aber genau betrachtet
entspricht es eigentlich dem was man
erwarten konnte auch aus den
zulassungsstudien denn wir wussten von
vornherein dass wenn sie hundert
menschen impfen zb das dann eben eine
gewisse anzahl von menschen nicht
ausreichend geschützt sein wird selbst
wenn sie diese grundimmunisierung
bekommen hat insofern kann man jetzt
nicht so tun als wäre es erstaunlich
wenn das tatsächlich auch stattfindet
hinzu kommt ein gewisses werning der
immunität aber dieses training also das
nachlassen der immunität bezieht sich
nach allen internationalen studien
wesentlichen auf den schutz vor
infektionen und nicht auf den schutz vor
erkrankungen das heißt mit anderen
worten diejenigen die grundimmunisierung
sind und die sonst gesund sind und den
in dem mittleren alter sich befinden die
können tatsächlich davon ausgehen dass
sie jetzt noch ausreichenden schutz von
ihrer grundimmunisierung für schwere
erkrankungen haben und noch mal das ziel
der impfung ist primär immer den schutz
vor erkrankungen zu erzeugen das gilt
auch für andere impfstoffe auch wenn das
in vergessenheit gerät wenn man das
genau sich anschaut so gibt es
eigentlich wahrscheinlich nur sehr wenig
impfstoffe die eine so genannte sterile
immunität hervorrufen können also die
dann bewirken können dass eine der
geimpfte sich nicht mehr infiziert das
ist eine sehr hohe forderung und wird
auch zb von einem schlichten rütteln
impfstoff nicht erreicht also die mit
anderen worten die durchbruch aktionen
die jetzt registriert werden
entsprechend eigentlich ungefähr dem was
man auch erwarten konnte aus dem
zusammenspiel von
primären im versagern auch in
zulassungsstudien dokumentiert und den
tatsächlich etwas nachlassenden
immunität die sich aber nicht auf die
schutzwirkung für schwere erkrankungen
bezieht was müssen wir tun im winter aus
sicht der stiko jetzt es müssen
unbedingt die menschen geimpft werden
die kein normales reagierendes
immunsystem haben die also in
irgendeiner weise immunsupprimierten
sind dazu gibt es eine empfehlung und
das ist sehr wichtig bei diesen menschen
wissen wir dass je nach
immunsuppressiven und immunsupprimierten
ein breites spektrum von patienten das
je nach innen suppression bis zu 50
prozent von diesen also keinen guten
schutz aufgrund der immunisierung
entwickeln konnten und die müssen also
unbedingt
gepostet oder auf gespräch werden das
andere und das ist von unserer
empfehlung erfasst in diesem
zusammenhang sind die menschen die nur
mit einer
impfdosis des johnson johnson impfstoffs
kämpfen sind die sollten sich jetzt auf
postern lassen weil es tatsächlich auch
in deutschland fassbar ist über das rkw
dass es hier vermehrt zu durchbohren
infektionen kommt bei diesen kämpften
was unter uns gesagt mich persönlich
jetzt jedenfalls nicht so
gewaltig überrascht hat auch nach der
ansonsten müssen wir die eben über
70-jährigen inseln warum gerade die über
70-jährigen weil wir durch analyse der
daten feststellen konnten dass in diesem
alter das risiko für schwere erkrankung
bei
erfolgter infektion ansteigt und es ist
ja sinnvoll zuerst die zu kämpfen die
das auch am dringendsten brauchen hinzu
kommt das medizinische personal das
geimpft werden soll und zwar aus einer
anderen indikation heraus natürlich auch
einzelne zum selbstschutz aber andere
vor allen dingen damit ist das virus
nicht übertragen können aufholen haben
personen die sie pflegen oder für die
sie verantwortlich sind und sie wissen
ja jetzt auch das ist auch dass gerade
jetzt eine ganz interessante publikation
aus england gekommen ist die zeigt dass
eben auch menschen die sich nach
erfolgreicher impfung re infizieren also
erneut infizieren dass die auch virus
ausscheiden können und insofern das ist
sehr sinnvoll das pflegepersonal zu
impfen jetzt komme ich aber auch vor
allen dingen auf diese gruppe die uns
etwas probleme macht und das wäre die
grundimmunisierung bei den
18 bis 59 jährigen sie wissen selbst
dass wir durchschnittlich vielleicht
etwa 72
impfquote haben das aber von land zu
land in deutschland deutlich schwankt
also es geht fast runter bis auf 60
prozent und das ist natürlich
unzureichend und jetzt sage ich ihnen
was wenn sie jetzt rufen dass wir alle
menschen zum dritten mal impfen sollten
dann sage ich ihnen aber das kann ja zum
beispiel nicht für die gegend gelten die
schon die erste und die zweite impfung
nicht gekriegt haben und das sind ja
sozusagen
daumen gepeilt ungefähr 30 prozent also
insofern kommt es jetzt wirklich darauf
an zuerst mal die zu schützen die die
impfungen am dringendsten nötig haben
und zu versuchen diese impfquote der
grundimmunisierung wieder zu heben na
gut ok
administration wir können und das ist ja
auch in unserer empfehlung enthalten
empfehlen dass das betrifft die
hausärzte auch die termine der hausarzt
sind dass eben die
die grippeimpfung und die
gegebenenfalls infizierte mit 19 empfing
am gleichen termin an zwei
unterschiedlichen stellen gegeben werden
können natürlich nicht dass man die
beiden impfstoffe in einer spritze
aufziehen kann gut das ist aus meiner
sicht das was ich zum eingang sagen
wollte und bin gespannt was sie sonst
noch wissen wollen danke dafür
vielen dank frau wolf sehr geehrte damen
und herren als wissenschaftliche
gesellschaft für den hausärztlichen
versorgungsbereich
setzen wir die wissenschaftlichen
rahmenbedingungen des hausärztlichen
arbeitens und um das vorwegzunehmen wir
schließen uns in allen punkten der
ständigen impfkommission an
wie blicken wir auf diesen uns
bevorstehenden winter wachsam aber nicht
ohne zuversicht wir haben mehr mittel in
der hand als letztes jahr wir hatten
letztes jahr nur den infektionsschutz
mit kontakt beschränkungen mit dem
basismaßnahmen und den tests das haben
wir jetzt alles auch noch uns zusätzlich
das impfen und da ist es wichtig dass
wir in der reihenfolge vorgehen wie von
der stiko empfohlen das heißt das
instrumentarium dass wir jetzt zur
verfügung haben das wird sich in den
nächsten jahren wahrscheinlich nicht
groß ändern insofern kann man sagen dass
dieses diese situation jetzt eine
blaupause sein kann für die nächsten
jahre des virus wird nicht weggehen das
instrumentarium wird sich nicht groß
ändern wir haben einige kann
empfehlungen drin für pharma
biotherapeutika für den hausärztlichen
bereichen unserer leitlinie aber das
wundermittel ist bislang nicht in sicht
das heißt wir werden auch in den
nächsten wintern mit den mitteln
auskommen müssen wahrscheinlich die wir
jetzt haben und deshalb wird sich das
jetzt auch zeigen ob wir das hinkriegen
das zu tun was wirklich wichtig ist und
ich komme zu unserem zweiten punkt zum
einem zweiten punkt nämlich den schutz
der alten und pflegeheime das ist aus
unserer sicht absolut prioritär die
älteren und wonach apple zu schützen das
müssen wir diesmal besser machen als
letztes jahr und zwar durch
diejenigen
grund immunisieren die noch nicht grund
improvisiert sind die alten um
pflegekräfte
natürlich die auffrischen die das 70
lebensjahr überschritten haben das heißt
die bewohner boostern die pflegekräfte
impfen regelmäßige pool testungen machen
und selbstverständlich auch ganz
konsequent einträge verhindern das heißt
es muss dann auch jedes pflegeheim in
irgendeiner art und weise
bewerkstelligen dass durch
eingangskontrollen tagesbesucher keine
einträge machen und der dritte und
letzte punkt wir brauchen
dafür natürlich die von dr gassen
angesprochene ruhe im system das heißt
wir sollten nicht davon ablenken was
wichtig ist
prioritär ist die zu impfen die den
schutz am allermeisten brauchen und wenn
die politik sozusagen immer vorprescht
das erste wort hat die stiko dann das
zweite wort das letzte wort ein
künstlicher zeitdruck erzeugt wird und
die vielen hausärztlichen kolleginnen
und kollegen
das dann auffangen müssen dann sind das
in den praxen sehr zeit fressende
diskussionen und hier geht es aber nicht
irgendwie um befindlichkeiten sondern es
geht wirklich darum dass man die
kolleginnen und kollegen ihren job
machen lässt und das tun lässt was jetzt
wirklich wichtig ist sie kennen alle das
wort das wir uns nach der pandemie
wahrscheinlich viel zu verzeihen haben
aus medizinischer sicht wäre
unverzeihlich dass
den fehler des letzten jahres zu
wiederholen nämlich da wo wir am
schwächsten war
nämlich beim schutz der alten und
pflegeheim das heißt dass die
systemrelevante gruppe der hausärzte und
hausärzte ihre arbeit gut machen kann
dafür brauchst die bereits
angesprochenen rahmenbedingungen vielen
dank auch dafür und dann last but not
least
vielen dank und schönen tag auf meiner
seite sehr geehrten herrn ich darf auf
den praktischen teil der umsetzung
eingehen wie das in der ambulanten
versorgung aussehen dazu gestatten sie
mir einen kurzen rückblick und dann den
ausblick wir haben mehrfach gehört dass
wir durchaus zuversichtlich sind auch
wenn jetzt die zahlen steigen dass wir
mit diesem winter mit der letzten
kraftanstrengung dann auch die
schwersten teil dieser pandemie
überwinden werden können und wir alle
wissen schafft ärztin ärzte und
politiker in politiker sollten unserer
einschätzung nach sich jetzt darauf
konzentrieren
positive botschaften klare botschaften
zu machen zu geben und keine angst zu
machen selbstverständlich bei aller
weiteren nötigen umsicht die letzten
anderthalb jahre waren ein gewaltiger
kraftakt für alle auch und besonders für
die niedergelassenen kolleginnen
kollegen und deren teams in den praxen
immer wieder haben uns berichte erreicht
von praxen die am limit ihrer
belastungsgrenze oder auch darüber
hinaus arbeiten das geht seit über
anderthalb jahren so und das ist sicher
etwas was wir berücksichtigen müssen
aber die niedergelassenen ihre teams
haben die herausforderung angenommen und
bewältigt sie haben den im fuster
gezündet im sommer sie haben dreieinhalb
millionen impfungen die woche geschafft
haben großartiges geleistet und wir
vergessen es immer gerne neben er ja
auch noch etwa 1,3 milliarden arzt
patientenkontakte bewältigt bei etwa 700
millionen fällen das heißt wir haben ja
auch noch andere sehr kranke menschen
die wir jeden tag betreuen begleiten und
therapieren müssen natürlich gab es
fehler rückblickend aller beteiligter
vor anderthalb jahren konnte niemand
genau wissen was richtig ist und wir
haben alle dazugelernt jetzt schauen wir
nach vorne was also brauchen wir für den
herbst für die wahrscheinlich letzte
etappe in dieser großen pandemie wir
brauchen vor allem einen klaren fahrplan
verlässliche ansagen zum beispiel wann
ist die booster impfung sinnvoll für wen
und wie und wer sollte sich zusätzlich
gegen grippe impfen lassen die
prioritäten sind aus sicht der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung sehr
klar erstens umgehende und möglichst
vollständige booster impfung für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger denen die stiko
eine auffrischimpfung empfiehlt zweitens
möglichst viele noch ungeimpfte
erwachsene vom nutzen der impfung
überzeugen dass als vor allem klare
informationen und persönliche angebote
im übrigen ist und bleibt das impfen und
die aufklärung eine rein ärztliche
aufgabe gerade dann wenn bei manchen
menschen und wir hören dass er in den
medien immer wieder ängste
unsicherheiten weiterhin im spiel sind
und auch kolportiert werden die praxen
stehen dafür bereit und sie können diese
impfungen auch die anstehenden buß der
impfungen zahlenmäßig leisten sie können
aber nicht die berechtigten einzeln ab
telefonieren und einladen zumal in den
praxen und auch in den kassen den
vereinigungen dafür überhaupt keine
daten da sind das wäre nicht leistbar
auch nicht neben dem sonst auch im
winter bestehenden intensiven
arbeitsbelastungen in den praktischen
anstatt also den praxen jetzt vorwürfe
zu machen nach anderthalb jahren
härtesten einsatz wie man es
gelegentlich jetzt hört könnte durch
bürokratie abbauen geringfügige
anpassungen der rahmenbedingungen sowie
einheitliche informationspolitik die
arbeit der praxen ganz wesentlich
erleichtert werden wir empfehlen
gezielte einladung durch krankenkassen
oder behörden wie das land berlin das
zum beispiel ganz geräuschlos macht und
eine entsprechende informations und
werbekampagne mit eindeutigen
botschaften wie es sie bereits im
frühjahr gegeben hat und wir betonen
auch wie es professor scherer gerade
gemacht hat erneut ausdrücklich den
wichtigen schutz der personen in alten
und pflegeheimen
diese sollten sich mit den betreuenden
ärzten absprechen und die impfungen der
bewohner und natürlich auch der
mitarbeitenden zu organisieren mobile
teams können hierbei unterstützen dazu
aber sagen dass diese mobilen teams ja
in der regel auch durch ärzte aus dem
niedergelassenen bereich besetzt werden
das heißt dort ist tatsächlich jede
unterstützung hilfreich und wichtig
politisch und das eine wichtige
botschaft ist die freiwilligkeit der
korona impfung beschlossen worden das
kann so gemacht werden dann kann im
gegenzug aber natürlich nicht das
erreichen bestimmter impfquoten zur
voraussetzung gemacht werden
restriktionen für alle also auch die
geimpften nicht zurückzunehmen
freiwilligkeit ist ein wichtiges gut
dazu hat man sich entschieden soll das
impfen freiwillig bleiben dann sind wir
zwingend darauf angewiesen dass die
bevölkerung mitarbeiter das geht nur
wenn wir die menschen gewinnen und
überzeugen und dafür ist die
mindestvoraussetzung klare eindeutige
schafft positive botschaften von keine
drohszenarien der als kbv als vertrag
setzen vertrag herz der haben diese
botschaft ganz einfach nochmal erstens
falls noch nicht geschehen lassen sie
sich impfen zweitens für alle gelten die
empfehlungen der stiko drittens das
heißt auffrischung der zeit ab 70 jahre
und für medizinisches und pflegerisches
personal jeden alters sowie einzelne
weitere integrationen gemäss seco wie
schon ausgeführt war professor ernst und
viertens impfen schützt zuverlässig vor
schwerer erkrankungen das ist die
kernbotschaft die maßnahme die einen
ausweg aus der pandemie und allen damit
verbundenen einschränkungen bietet ist
die impfung und sie steht weiterhin
allen bürgerinnen und bürgern kostenlos
zur verfügung vielen dank danke auch
dafür am angesichts der länge der
frageliste weiß ich jetzt noch mal
darauf hin dass wieder eine frage und
gegebenenfalls nachfrage hat und ich
würde sie bitten ihre frage zu
adressieren um möglichst vielen
kolleginnen also an einen deckel auf dem
podium klar zu adressieren wir möglichst
vielen kolleginnen und kollegen die
möglichkeit zu geben zu fragen und ich
beginne bei herrn bringen
wie sollen ärzte damit umgehen wenn
menschen unter 70 jahre eine booster
impfung wollen
das natürlich ein szenario vielen dank
für diese frage dass auch dadurch
getriggert wird das sozusagen dieser
bedarf künstlich erzeugt wird durch
öffentliche statements aber das sind
genau die diskussion die wir in den
praxen haben und diese diskussion muss
man evidenzbasiert führen dass man muss
sich das anhören auf diesen wunsch ein
gehen und dann natürlich ganz klar sagen
die wissenschaftlichen empfehlungen
sprechen eine andere sprache
und dann muss man nach der aufklärung
sehen dass man zu einer guten
entscheidung kommt also wie sollen sie
damit umgehen auf die patienten und
patienten eingehen aber schon dann auch
die argumente bringen die professor
mertens eben vorgetragen hat
eine nachfrage martens ein doppelt
geimpfte mensch unter 60 jahren ohne
vorerkrankungen soll der überhaupt
zwingend eine infektion vermeiden oder
kann er diese jetzt eigentlich auch ganz
gut in kauf nehmen weil es ein booster
effekt hat
das ist eine sehr interessante frage und
natürlich muss man das ja ihre frage
auch auf die nächsten jahre projizieren
dazu sagen wollen wir künftig alle jahre
die folgen jede impfung durch jede
infektion durch impfung vermeiden und
auch deshalb komme ich darauf zurück
wichtig ist es zunächst die kämpfe bei
denen wir wissen schon durch
vorerkrankungen so dass sie ein risiko
für schwere erkrankungen haben also das
ist eine frage die wir derzeit sehr
intensiv diskutiert nicht nur
diskutieren sondern analysieren aber ich
sage nicht so sehr im hinblick auf den
schutz dieses individuums sondern im
hinblick darauf was das für die
transmission in der bevölkerung bedeuten
könnte also modell ist weil wenn sie so
wollen und das ist natürlich etwas was
wirklich sehr wichtig und interessant
ist und das beschäftigt die stiko kann
ich ihnen ganz offen sagen im augenblick
sehr und wir werden also über kurz oder
lang natürlich auch dazu stellung nehmen
müssen ob eine solche impfung der unter
60-jährigen jetzt nicht aus der
indikation des individual schutzes so
sehr sondern aus der indikation der
unterbrechung von transmission oder
verminderung von transmission sinnvoll
sein kann
aber ich darf ich noch anfügen denken
sie immer daran 30 prozent in der
entscheidenden mobilen altersgruppe sind
noch nicht geimpft sozusagen für
diejenigen steht keine dritte impfung
kann sondern da stehen die ersten beiden
impfungen an und das muss man immer
wieder betonen damit die diskussion
nicht in die iv und die nicht in die
falsche richtung läuft
spiekermann zdf haben jetzt eigentlich
durch die bank dafür plädiert dass für
einen sortiertes vorgehen also bei der
booster impfung also priorität
wie hilfreich ist es da der
geschäftsführende minister sagt nicht
dafür alle an den richtig fahren wer
lust hat
dazu aus der sicht der praxis wir habe
es gerade gehört auch die frage an den
scherer sie müssen sich vorstellen wie
viel zeit die praxen verbrauchen um mit
verunsicherten menschen zur zeit zu
reden in dieser zeit wird weder geimpft
noch werden andere menschen behandelt
das heißt das geht von ihrer zeit ab wie
loriot sagen würde und das hilft uns
nicht wir brauchen klare botschaften und
ich habe auch eine persönliche meinung
zum impfen die verkündet ich hier nicht
wir haben eine ständige impfkommission
die es besetzt die ist genau dafür
gemacht und das ist in einer solchen
situation wo wir priorisieren müssen
ratsam dass man nach einem klaren
gezielten vorgehen vor rät und das
verstehen auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger werden wenn sie alle zwei wochen
eine andere botschaft kriegen das
misstrauen wächst und die verunsicherung
wächst und die müssen wir in den praxen
wieder mühsamen einholen und und
reparieren und das kostet zeit die wir
nicht haben ich würde das gerne ergänzen
wenn ich gerade
ergänzend ist genau wie hofmeister
gesagt hat der der punkt ist ja der wir
haben diese relativ hohe quote von nicht
geimpften so jetzt muster impfungen
wahllos für alle zu empfehlen macht
keinen sinn wenn wir tatsächlich eine
klare indikation haben für menschen die
jetzt im anstehenden winter besonders
gefährdet sind und das sind dann immer
die über 70-jährigen als auch gesagt
altenheime da sind da spielt ja
tatsächlich infekt vom
krankheitsgeschehen die musik und
deshalb ist müssen wir die
geordnet abarbeiten das kriegen wir auch
hin und solange wir nicht eine impfquote
von 80-90 gedanken darüber machen ob der
sterilität erzeugen und die datenlage
ist momentan die sich her gehen ob das
überhaupt passiert und von daher ist
auch klar dass wir alle sehr stringent
an der stiko empfehlung hängen
nur eins anführen weil das wenn schon
gefragt worden ist oder gesagt worden
ist natürlich ist es immer besser
jemanden zu impfen als den impfstoff weg
zu schmal sind das haben wir schon bei
der ersten priorität gesagt und das
bleibt natürlich auch so soll keinen
impfstoff weggeschmissen werden also
wenn sie aufgrund der gebinde impfstoff
übrig haben dann ist es in jedem fall
besser noch mal jemanden zu impfen als
das nicht zu tun dass wir nicht sagen
aber auch hier und das kann nicht nur
anschließen es geht ja um sozusagen
wieder eine gewisse art der
priorisierung zusätzlich zur frage ob
wir durch generelle änderung eine
biologische effekt erzeugen können und
das wird sich das müssen wir noch
herausfinden
ganz kurze ergänzung ist ein
wesentliches prinzip in der medizin das
wichtige zuerst zu tun und zuerst die zu
impfen die am meisten davon profitieren
und nicht die die am schnellsten laufen
können und deshalb brauchen wir das
geordnete vorgehen
anfragen doch zu kinderimpfungen darf
ich dann nehme ich sie noch mal mit auf
die liste weiterer neuer also das ist
eine sehr sehr lange frageliste da
werden wir ohnehin nicht ganz durch
kommen dass fall schon mal vorweg
genommen der kollege rinke von der
agentur reuters fragt digital an sie
herr mertens ist es nicht zeit dass
angesichts der eu weiten zulassung von
impfstoffen auch die impfempfehlungen
europaweit erfolgen sollten und es ist
ein gespräch bzw gibt es absprachen dazu
ja war natürlich das wäre mein wunsch
oder wunschziel oder auch meinen traum
und es gibt ja auch gewisse interaktion
zwischen den so genannten neuen tags das
sind sozusagen die stiko analoge aber
sie müssen 1 bedenken so eine stiko wie
in deutschland gibt es in europa nicht
so häufig also als unabhängiges
expertengremium die meisten
impfkommission sind ja angepflanzt an
ein jeweiliges ministerium und es gibt
auch ganz andere voraussetzungen im
gesundheitssystem und es gibt ganz
andere voraussetzungen bei der
erstellung sozusagen von impfplänen und
es gibt auch länder die haben oft keine
stiko zb in italien da weiß ich dass nun
also mit anderen worten ja das wäre
absolut sinnvoll dass letztendlich zu
machen aber das ist schwierig und
sozusagen auch eine vereinigung der
empfehlungs gebenden gremien der
verschiedenen länder hätte keinerlei
exekutiv funktion die können nichts
durchsetzen so zu sagen da brauchen wir
natürlich den politischen willen auch
dass so etwas geschehen kann und den
kann ich so im augenblick noch nicht so
richtig erkennen wenn herr koch
r merken es die intensivmediziner
vereinigung die die als vor einigen
monaten vorgerechnet dass wir angesichts
der großen zahl von impfungen uns quasi
instanzen von 300 bis 400 leisten in
anführungsstrichen
vor die große zahl von intensivpatienten
wie im winter wieder erreicht wird wie
stehen sie zu der
oft beschworenen gefahr der überlastung
der intensivstation die jetzt auch noch
mal eintreten können
und das ist überhaupt nicht mein
fachgebiet und das gleich zu sagen und
ich äußere mich eigentlich nur ungern zu
über sachen von denen ich nicht wirklich
was verstehe aber was ich ihnen sagen
kann es natürlich dass in diesem
zusammenhang auf jeden fall an die
grippeimpfung wieder zu denken ist also
an den pflanzen denn eins ist ja ganz
klar wenn wir jetzt eine steigende zahl
von intensiv pflichtigen patienten
bekommen wegen cupid 19 und wenn wir
dann zusätzlich noch eine was wir nicht
vorhersehen können aber zum um die
weihnachtszeit kommt fängt das ja in der
regel bei uns an eine heftige
grippewelle bekommen influenzawelle dann
wäre das natürlich sehr kontraproduktiv
in ihrem sinne und von daher kann ich
nur noch mal darauf verweisen dass man
nicht nur immer nur auf cupid 19 schauen
sollte es gibt auch noch andere
infektionen und in dem fall die grippe
und noch eins möglich an dessen sagen es
ist natürlich schön wenn man sich nach
g2 oder g3 in einem großen festsaal
trifft ohne sonstige schutzmaßnahme dann
ist das mit kuwait okay aber die
influenza kann dann natürlich zum
beispiel fröhliche feste feiern das muss
man auch sagen
insofern erinnere ich noch mal daran
dass wir nicht nur kranke menschen dann
aufkommt haben und das ist jetzt schon
auch mehrfach gesagt werden sondern es
gibt ja auch andere ursachen jetzt im
winter eine
infektionskrankheit und auch eine
schwere infektionskrankheit zu erleiden
unter umständen
die kolleginnen mißlbeck vom ärzte
nachrichtendienst fragt sie herr gassen
verzeichnen es wurde auch schon
angeklungen aber vielleicht noch mal
konkret verzeichnen die arztpraxen einen
rahmen von patienten die nun eine
auffrischung wollen obwohl sie obwohl
diese von der stiko nicht empfohlen ist
und dann nochmal angeschlossen und ist
es geht es ihrer meinung nach auf
politische äußerungen zurück also brawn
können wir jetzt nicht so berichten es
gibt diese fälle immer mal wieder in
praxen professor schon darauf
hingewiesen dass das auch in praxen
erheblichen beratungsbedarf auslöst und
natürlich wenn wird das nicht durch
ärztliche empfehlung hervorgerufen
sondern durch politische äußerungen
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe den
sie ja alle fälle etwas mehr
gelassenheit
meine frage einer mertens reicht ihnen
dann das impf tempo für die von also für
die personengruppen die sie jetzt
empfohlen haben also die über
70-jährigen denn davon gibt es ja auch
noch
über 10 15 millionen die nicht geimpft
sind denn glaube es sind erst zwei
millionen der über 60 jahren geimpft und
daran aufbauen terrassen was halten sie
denn von der forderung die impfzentren
wieder zu öffnen und das tempo zu
erhöhen ja also sie haben diese menge
der menschen genannt das sind 15
millionen bis ende des jahres nach stiko
empfehlungen die booster impfung
bekommen sollten jetzt muss man sagen es
ist ja nicht so präsent und wird mich
korrigieren wenn ich unseren erzähle
dass nach ablauf der sechs monate nach
der zweiten empfänger nicht schlagartig
der impfschutz versagt sondern wir
wissen dann singt er ab individuelle
unterschiede nicht das weiß man ja auch
nicht präzise deshalb wird ja empfohlen
ab dem sechsten monat und es sollten
mindestens sechs monate seien die
auferstehung zu machen ihre frage zu
beantworten ja das kriegen wir bis ende
des jahres geordnet hin und die
impfzentren lösen das problem deshalb
nicht weil es ja nicht darum geht
dass wir jetzt große kochten die mobil
sind an einem aus schnell durch müssen
sondern dass gerade das dezentrale der
praxen eigentlich das bessere setting
ist um diese impfung durchzuführen
es wäre gut wenn das schnell geht
sozusagen die menschen zu enten
aufzufrischen wir reden ich rede jetzt
von auf beschimpfungen die ebendies
besonders benötigen das ist sozusagen
mein antwort auf ihre frage aber ich
weiß sehr genau und das wissen sie auch
das ist ja in vieler hinsicht auch sache
der länder jetzt letztendlich und also
ich meine jetzt nicht die ärzteschaft
das ist schon klar aber sie wie man das
organisiert wie man zb die älteren
menschen die es nötig haben auch dazu
bringt jetzt zu ihrem hausarzt zu gehen
das ist ja ein mögliches problem und das
wiederum ist ein organisatorisches
problem was aus meiner kenntnis ja eher
auf der ebene der länder gelöst werden
müsste die kollegin
wir sagten jetzt muss schnell gehen aber
geht es im moment schnell genug
ich kann ihnen das ehrlich gesagt nicht
wirklich gut beantworten weil ich die
daten nicht kenne ich weiß nicht ob
jemand von den kollegen hier also wir
haben von es ist ja wie gesagt
kontrollieren das verfahren weil die
sechs monate ja natürlich
unterschiedlich ablaufen menschen sind
ja nicht alle zum gleichen zeitpunkt
zwei kämpft und da sind wir natürlich
noch hinterher gesagt nur zwei millionen
sind geimpft aber es müssten sollten
eigentlich gemäß der menge der kohorte
die wir bis april geimpft haben er vier
bis fünf millionen seien insofern ja
dann müssen wir noch ein bisschen
nachlegen und da ist das entscheidende
aber nicht die frage ob man im plan
sondern es geht tatsächlich man gezielt
ist ein leitungssystem viele menschen
wissen ja gar nicht dass sie gepostet
werden sollen stattdessen gibt es
derartige äußerung alle ab 18 jeder der
mag nein wichtig ist dass die gemäss
stiko gehen sollen und das sollte am
besten überwachungsverfahren berlin
macht es so schön die heime sollte
organisieren und dann kann man die
entweder in die praxis oder mit mobilen
impfen und dann kriegen wir
geschwindigkeit
[Musik]
die druck auf medizinisches personal und
beschäftigte in senioreneinrichtungen
für richtig sich boostern zu lassen oder
sollte dies der freien entscheidung der
betroffenen überlassen sein also wir
haben vorhin gesagt grundsätzlich die
entscheidung eine freiwillige
entscheidung das gilt natürlich auch für
die booster impfung und ich finde es
ehrlicherweise an dem fast schwieriger
dass wir einen gewissen teil des
medizinischen pflegerischen personals
das noch gar nicht geimpft ist also da
das ist auch eine frage des
selbstverständnisses und hier kommt man
tatsächlich fast in erklärungsnöte weil
man sagt hier sollte keinen druck
aufgebaut werden also ich halte es für
sehr schwierig wenn pflegerisches
personal in einem pflegeheim nicht
geimpft ist dass die sich im zweifel
auch mal ostern also das ist eine andere
geschichte aber es gibt offensichtlich
schwanke neben spurten insgesamt glaube
ich ist das ärztliche personal dann auch
das pflegepersonal praxen in einem sehr
hohem umfang geimpft wahrscheinlich auch
in den meisten krankenhäusern
pflegeheimen es gibt aber durchaus da
impfquoten die zur sorge anlass geben
und deshalb würde ich dringend dafür
werben dass ich alle beschäftigten die
im weitesten sinne mit kranken oder
pflegebedürftigen menschen zu tun haben
auf jeden fall grund immunisieren lassen
und bei bedarf eben booster gemäss
studie empfehlen ihre frage hatte sich
tatsächlich gewinnen dann bin ich bei
ihnen rechts vorne von ihnen aus gesehen
links beim wahlforum das wochenmagazin
ich fahre noch mal zu den seniorenheim
an herrn dr gass in einer professor
martens hätte man die zehn toten in
rheinland pfalz die 14 toten am
schwielowsee hierbei berlin hätte man
die verhindern können hätte man einfach
6 8 wochen früher angefangen mit der
dritten impfung
also ich glaube es ist immer sehr
schwierig sie können nicht jeden
individuellen tod verhindern ich glaube
das ist das ist auch eine antwort die
man auch mal geben muss man es wird ja
manchmal der eindruck erweckt wenn man
nur das und das täten dann stirbt
niemand an krone das wird nicht so sein
die menschen werden auch sterben und
möglich aber sind da auch menschen
verstorben die so viele wohnt
erkrankungen dass auch eine booster
impfung sie nicht kaufen aber um das zu
minimieren um die zahl derjenigen zu
minimieren die solche verläuft dann ist
es natürlich sinnvoll sie zu ostern aber
das jetzt konkret sollen wir das wäre
ein blick in die glaskugel
dem kann ich mich nur anschließen sie
verleiten nicht zu spekulieren und wie
gesagt dass paris
aber ist ja schon auffällig dass da
jetzt plötzlich ihr in schwielowsee
14 menschen ältere menschen die geimpft
sind zweimal geimpft sind das die dann
bei einem corona eintritt was rein
getragen wurde durch pfleger wohl durch
den schwielowsee hier zumindest dass die
dann ganz schnell versterben obwohl sie
geimpft sind
und das ist durch zwei dinge erklärt war
zum einen das sagte schon die ist nicht
jeder auch zweimal kämpfte wirklich
geschützt und wir wissen es im
individual fall eben nicht ob er
geschützt so nicht dass das eine und
auch da wissen wir dass die qualität der
immunität nach impfung in den in der
älteren bevölkerung schlechter ist als
in der jüngeren gesunden bevölkerung
dass der eine teil der antwort den
anderen teil der antwort denn sie gerne
hören würden nämlich die frage inwieweit
dort ein rating also einen verlust
bereits formal existierender immunität
schon in eine rolle spielt ist sehr
schwer zu beantworten kann einen
gewissen effekt spielen aber die daten
aus unserer gesamtbevölkerung sprechen
eigentlich nicht dafür dass sozusagen
der schutz vor schwere erkrankung schon
so weit zurückgegangen ist dass man
jetzt so damit rechnen muss warum das
jetzt dort so ist kann ich ihnen nicht
beantworten
ja und aus der praktischen sicht also
die kasuistik so tragisch sind die
lassen sich einfach nicht klären
rückwirkend aber es weist noch mal
deutlich darauf hin dass dort unser
augenmerk gehen muss wie vor einem jahr
das sind die senioren und pflegeheime
dort sind die menschen die erstens als
und zweitens in der regel co
erkrankungen haben und damit ohnehin ein
hohes risiko haben zu versterben an
allerlei effekten und deswegen ist die
konzentration auf die jetzt geboten und
das muss in der nötigen geschwindigkeit
jetzt fortgesetzt werden und ich glaube
da sind alle dran darauf sollten wir uns
konzentrieren
ich würde ihre zahlen die schlimm genug
sind durch schlimmere zahlen ergänzen
die uns allen bekannt sind nämlich dass
nach der zweiten welle von den 70.000
verstorbenen
29 also knapp 30.000 eben in alten und
pflegeheimen
zu beklagen waren
das zeigt einfach einmal mehr wir müssen
die kräfte bündeln und uns auf das
konzentrieren wo wirklich großes leid zu
verhindern ist dass das so nicht noch
mal passieren
eine frage an herrn kasten sie haben
relativ klar geäußert dass sie wenig
verständnis haben für
pflegepersonal das nicht geimpft ist und
sieht auch so aus dass die zahlen nicht
so gehen an sie die frage ist nicht eine
verpflichtende innenhofes personal
dringend aus ihrer sicht und wenn ich
darf eine frage an ob es vermerken ist
für meine kollegen sind norddeutschen
rundfunks schließt sich an den komplex
eben an die kollegen berichten von
ausbrüchen den altersheimen
ältere herrschaften krank geworden sind
auch nach dem muster im juni haben wir
das zu beurteilen
also sie wissen auch dass ich kein fan
von ihm pflichten bin ich bin jemand der
eigentlich die eingefahren verhör stellt
das ist allerdings bei in diesen
bereichen dann tatsächlich problematisch
wenn wir im quoten haben die vielleicht
nur bei 60 70 prozent liegen da muss man
sich hier die frage wirklich stellen das
muss man auch diskutieren zumindest
würde ich anregen dass die menschen die
das pflegepersonal was dann nicht
geimpft ist kann eigentlich keinen
patienten kontakt haben das ist aus
meiner sicht doch mit einer gewissen
gefahr versehen und ob man dann eben
schlicht tatsächlich für die
geschäftlichen medizinischen bereich
machen will muss an anderer stelle
diskutiert werden ja und das muss man
noch mal ganz klar sagen eine jede form
der impfpflicht ist eine politische
entscheidung und es ist keine
wissenschaftliche entscheidung das
müsste man mal endlich klar haben es
müssen sozusagen unsere von uns
gewählten volksvertreter für uns alle
entscheiden ob es eine impfpflicht in
irgendeinem bereich geben soll oder
nicht und sozusagen das an diese frage
immer an uns fürchten wir sind die
falschen adressaten tatsächlich für
diese wir können zwar meinungen äußern
dazu aber letztendlich muss man klar
sagen da muss die politik dann sich
entscheiden wird ob sie so was machen
will oder ob sie so etwas nicht machen
will und das ist eine entscheidung die
für unser gemeinwesen getroffen werden
kann ja
die ich mache jetzt erstmal weiter
verhaltene nachfrage wegen der fälle
nach uster impfung das kann ich
überhaupt nicht beantwortet so muss man
wirklich sehr genau kennen wie die
zeitlichen abläufe sind wann sind die
gepostet worden wann sind die infiziert
worden was es wie genau passiert also
ich will mich gerne darum kümmern aber
da muss man tatsächlich genau wissen wie
sind da die abläufe gewesen
unser immunsystem braucht immer etwas
zeit das ist bei der dritten impfung
weniger als bei der ersten und der
zweiten impfung ganz klar wenn der
größenordnung von einer woche müssen sie
auf jeden fall rechnen es hängt aber
auch plötzlich davon ab wie gut der
betreffende organismus tatsächlich auf
die impfung reagieren kann verstehen sie
es ist keine also eine ganz allgemeine
aussage zu sagen nach sechs tagen ist
das da das ist schwierig weil wir nicht
wissen im einzelfall wie geht es denn so
zu sagen wie fit ist der entsprechende
organismus immunologisch und wie gut
kann er reagieren aber einige tage
braucht es schon auch nach der dritten
impfung bis sie sozusagen wieder das ist
ja auch entschuldigung ganz klar wenn
sie sich den mechanismus des impfstoffes
vorstellen dann muss da wird eine mrsa
eingeführt die verbleibt vielleicht 14
tage im organismus dann ist sie weg auch
eine wichtige information gerade im
hinblick auf die auf die überlegung zu
risiken und dann in dieser zeit muss das
protein gebildet werden und dann muss
das immunsystem kontakt bekommen mit
diesem gebildeten proteinen und das
müssen die entsprechende antikörper und
die hoffentlich auch t zellen gemacht
werden und das braucht eine gewisse zeit
die queen sowie key von watson die evag
digital zur impfkampagne würde eine neue
zentrale impfkampagne wie sie der
vorsitzende des welt ärzte bundesmann
mary fordert bei der nachfrage nach den
booster impfungen helfen
lassen also ich glaube dass wir dafür
gerne allem eine impfkampagne machen was
wir erleben ja dass die impfkampagne im
prinzip von der unsichtbare wand fährt
wir haben einem wissen teil der
bevölkerung der sich offen sich nicht
für geld und gute worte im vest bei den
booster impfung geht es tatsächlich eher
um das erinnern das ist wie das von
daher haben wir ja vorgeschlagen das
wirklich eine art einladung zur
erinnerungs system beispielsweise
deutlich die krankenkassen oder wie hier
in berlin durchs land erfolgt weil die
menschen die gebucht werden sie sind ja
empfehle ich der berg eine kampagne dass
die sich jetzt impfen lassen sollen die
bauern in erinnerung dass wir noch
sozusagen eine ergänzende zusatz leben
verbauen dann bin ich eine kollegin
rechts hinten von ihnen aus gesehen
links landrat dr also sie lassen jetzt
alle hier eine deutliche unzufriedenheit
mit der politik erkennen können sie denn
mal sagen auch vielleicht wollen sie
konkret werden was eigentlich im zweiten
herz der panini von der politik
vielleicht auch vom
bundesgesundheitsminister nicht
verstanden wurde sondern bietet sich die
frage eigentlich im grunde an allen ja
nur die zeit haben ja nicht dass jeder
noch mal ausführlich vielleicht also an
herrn affen oder werde er sich irgendwie
berufen führt jetzt nicht beantworten
weil die unzufriedenheit einbindet
also ich es mal ganz kurz machen das
würde ich glaube dass verein und alle
wir würden einfach ganz gern unsere
arbeit machen und das möglichst ohne
dass wir dass wir da ständig gute
ratschläge bekommen und das in
abgesteckten rahmen bedingungen wenn das
gewährleiste ist das ist in vielen
teilen gewährleistet aber eben nicht in
allen wir leben jetzt gerade dass die
ersten regelungen zur fortsetzung
beispiel im vorjahr auf den weg gebracht
werden also passiert ja durchaus etwas
auch in ordnung ist aber ich glaube
politik sollte entweder und da bin ich
völlig bei professor mertens eine klare
ansagen machen mit impfpflicht etc oder
sich der ärztlichen empfehlung fügen was
schwierig ist wenn die wenn wir eine
ständige impfkommission haben die
machten empfehlung die ärzteschaft
stellt sich geschlossen hinter und
politik gibt dann eine empfehlung aus
bauch evidenz oder auch gut gemeint aber
gut gemeint ist nicht immer gut gemacht
also nochmal wir würden uns wünschen
dass wir bei ärztlichen themen
medizinischen themen auf er zur
mediziner wird und die empfehlungen dann
auch annimmt die antwort auf ihre frage
hat ja kürzlich die bundeskanzlerin
eigentlich gegeben die den schwächsten
punkt der pandemie bekämpfung benannt
hat das war der schutz erhalten und
pflegeheime und
wir müssen sehen dass wir uns auch auf
diesen punkt konzentrieren und keine
scheindiskussion oder nebenschauplätze
aufmachen und wendig sagt wir müssen uns
auf diesen punkt konzentrieren dann
heißt es dass es hier nicht nur um die
impfungen geht die an allererster stelle
aber wir müssen noch viel mehr kraft
darin investieren auch den
infektionsschutz den war vor einem jahr
als einziges instrument hatten den
natürlich auch weiter zu machen und die
einträge zu verhindern und da müssen wir
den fokus darauf legen und und nicht
ablenken
dann nehme ich an der stelle weil sie
ganz gut passt eine frage von den
kollegen rinke dazu haben merken sie
seien gefragt wir haben gesagt sie
lassen sich mich drängen aber können sie
in etwa sagen wann eine aussage über
eine impfung der fünf- bis zwölfjährigen
kommen könnte
gut dass mit dieser impfstoff muss es
zunächst mal für diese altersgruppe
zugelassen werden und es gibt zwar keine
mir bekannte offizielle äußerung der em
aber es gibt inoffizielle äußerungen aus
dem kreis der ma die gesagt haben dass
die bis mitte dezember bis mitte
dezember braucht um sozusagen sich klar
zu werden über die prüfung der daten für
die zulassung vor der zulassung kann es
keine impfung geben und wir sind sehr
bemüht auf der basis der daten die wir
übrigens erst seit etwa drei tagen haben
der zulassungsdaten
die empfehlung parallel vorzubereiten zu
den zur zulassung man muss aber auch
wieder ganz klar sagen es ist kein so
einfache frage letztendlich die frage
das den potenziellen nutzen der impfung
in dieser altersgruppe abzuwägen gegen
einen potenziellen
negativen effekte in die impfung haben
könnte in dieser altersgruppe das ist
aufgabe der stiko verstehen sie und das
hat nichts mit meinungsäußerung zu tun
sondern müssen versuchen dazu wirklich
die besten verfügbaren
wissenschaftlichen daten
zusammenzutragen und das werden wir auch
tun also ich kann ihnen sagen vor der
zulassung wird es keine empfehlung der
stiko geben aber noch mal bei ihm herr
merkens der kollege jessen fragt digital
wenn trotz doppelten impfschutz
infektion und wird ihren weitergabe
nicht ausgeschlossen sind sollten sich
dann auch doppelt geimpfte weiterhin
testen lassen bzw dann sollten sie das
tun
und sie wissen dass in zum beispiel sie
haben es gehört in österreich das ja
schon so auch bestandteil der maßnahmen
ist und natürlich können sie durch
zusätzliches testen diejenigen
herausfinden die möglicherweise
asymptomatisch also ohne selbst
krankheitssymptome zu haben infiziert
sind und unter umständen das virus
weitergeben können aber auch das muss
ich sagen epidemiologisch kann das in
vielen situationen sind machen wenn man
sozusagen zu vielen menschen hinzu
zusammen kommt letztendlich ist aber
auch dass eine entscheidung die
politisch getroffen werden muss welches
ausmaß an sicherheit wollen wir
erreichen und das ist jetzt die frage
also wie gehen wir mit risiken und
restrisiken um und
epidemiologisch ist es natürlich ganz
klar wenn sie alle kämpften und
gemessenen auch noch testen dann fischen
sie die unter umständen noch aus die
virus ausscheiden obwohl sie genesen und
oder geimpft worden sind und das ist
eine wenn sie wollen zusätzliche
schutzfunktionen die in gewissen
situationen sicher auch vor allen dingen
risikosituationen natürlich sind von
salz waren die wahrscheinlich gar und
und die frage wann wann sie das
empfehlen würden würde ich jetzt mal so
verstehen in welchen situationen sollte
man sich dann als doppelt geimpfter
testen lassen ersten teils oder was
würden sie empfehlen also wenn wir
beispielsweise zweig szenario dann
brauchen wir fast nicht mehr testen dass
wir nur genesene geimpfte sind was
selbst wenn ich noch ein bisschen virus
last tragen werden die wahrscheinlich
ernsthaft krank das ist eigentlich immer
nur dann wenn geimpfte und nicht geimpft
oder nicht gelesen und gelesen da
zusammenkommt dass es dann ein bisschen
mehr sicherheit für die für die nicht
geimpften aber unser appell ist ein ganz
anderer die leute sollten sich impfen
lassen das würde das ganze an der stelle
vielleicht nicht gänzlich überflüssig
man aber deutlich glätten dann bin ich
immer sein anwalt frank spiekermann ich
habe jetzt doch noch mal nachfragen zu
den fünf bis elf jahre alte schienen sie
ein bisschen direkter ins mikro sprechen
weil ich den hinweis bekommen dass das
digitale sterben das ist ja verstehen
hat es ist ja auch ohne maske also dass
in fünf bis elfjährigen die
amerikanische arzneimittelbehörde hat ja
schon mal gehört und
das wird wahrscheinlich dann möglich
sein aber wenn ich fit bin war die
entscheidung oder ist die entscheidung
gefallen hat und einer einzigen
zulassungsstudie und reicht das um auch
in deutschland darauf sozusagen
schlüssel zu ziehen
nein das reicht nicht als eine
übertragung für deutschland aber das hat
einen ganz anderen grund wir wissen aus
guten studien aus den vereinigten
staaten dass die krankheitslast bei
kindern in den vereinigten staaten
signifikant anders ist von das
krankheits lasko mit 19 die wir in
deutschland haben
lassen sie mich jetzt nicht darüber
spekulieren woran das liegen könnte aber
das ist ganz gut
erfasst worden und es gibt natürlich
auch hypothesen woran das liegen könnte
also mit anderen worten die
krankheitslast ist immer ein wichtiges
argument auch für die frage der
bewertung der abwägende bewertung der 1
empfehlung und die krankheitslast es in
den vereinigten staaten auch für kinder
anders als das bei uns der fall ist und
das müssen wir halt und deshalb können
wir auch dass ein amerikanisches
vorgehen nicht ohne weiteres ungeprüft
sozusagen als blaupause für unsere
empfehlung verwenden ist das beantworten
oder da habe ich
es eben tatsächlich nur eine einzige
zulassungsstudie ist natürlich kann
diese einige zulassungs diese
zulassungsstudie die kann nicht
ausschließen dass es zu nebenwirkungen
kommt beispiel myokarditis fälle die mit
einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 10.000
geimpften auftreten die können sie nach
mathematischen regeln nicht herausfinden
wenn sie letztendlich nur eine gruppe
von etwa 2.000 geimpften haben das ist
doch ganz klar und das ist ja auch teil
unseres problems und unseres ab unseres
problems bei der bewertung natürlich
weil man sagen muss diese
zulassungsstudien alle zulassungsstudien
haben nur eine limitierte aussagekraft
im hinblick auf mögliche seltene
nebenwirkung verwandte war nicht
unmittelbar ganz
okay ich habe jetzt noch drei fahren auf
der liste das heute glaube ich noch zu
machen sein die kollegin mißlbeck fragt
digital vermehrten schießen sehr gefragt
heute an sie noch mal können die
impfungen gegen grippe und cupid 19 auch
mit einem geringen zeitlichen abstand
etwa zwei tage gegeben werden oder nur
gleichzeitig oder mit 14 tagen abstand
nein das können sie beides machen also
können das einen termin machen sie
können das aber auch an getrennten
terminen waren es handelt sich ja um das
auch noch einmal klar zu sagen bei allen
diesen impfstoffen um tod impfstoffe
wäre mir ausdrücklich eine kombinierte
anwendung von lebend impfstoffen
ausgeschlossen und zwar deshalb weil wir
wissen dass die mrs
von einer relativ kräftige interferonen
induktion machten das könnte zum nicht
angehen von gleichzeitig verabreichen
leben impfstoffen führen also tot im
stoffe können sie am termin kombinieren
und können sie auch zeitlich versetzt
geben
der kollege meyer von dpa fragt sie herr
gassen die sagten es seien aktuell
30.000 praxen mit impfungen aktiv wie
viele kennen und müssen noch dazu kommen
und mit dem bus dann schnell genug für
den winter zu sein
ja das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen
ich kann ihnen die zahl nennen als wir
im maximum der impfkampagne wahrhaben
über 70.000 praxen geimpfter allerdings
eine schlagzahl von fast über
dreieinhalb millionen der woche gehabt
die brauchen wir wahrscheinlich in der
form nicht also ich sag mal so wenn der
großteil der hausärztlichen praxis noch
ein paar facharztpraxen das machen und
vielleicht auch die 30.000 kommen auf 5
6000 drauf dann wird das reichen wäre
dann sozusagen im gleichmäßigen fluss
die kohorten gemäss stiko empfehlungen
zeitgerecht abarbeiten können ich bleibe
noch bei ihnen der kollege kistler von
der nzz fragt ob sie weiterhin einen
freedom day fordern und falls ja wann
um das mal gerade zudem passt er jetzt
ganz gut also die aussage damals bezog
sich auf eine grundsätzliche auf
möglichkeit der aufhebung der
verpflichtenden staatlichen maßnahmen
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass
lanckorona vorbei ist oder sich niemand
mehr schützen muss und hatte immer zur
vorgabe dass man eine frist von sechs
bis acht wochen vor einer solchen
änderung laufen lässt damit sich
menschen so war es auch ein bisschen
gedacht als zusätzliche motivation sich
noch rechtzeitig impfen lassen können
und tatsächlich auch die chance haben
zwei wochen nach dem letzten impftermin
auch dann entsprechend immunität zu
haben grundsätzlich glaube ich werden
wir in der situation kommen da wir eine
stabile kurort am von menschen sich
nicht impfen lassen dass man überlegen
muss und auch das ist dann irgendwann
eine staatliche entscheidung macht man
verpflichtende maßnahmen für eine
gesamtbevölkerung wenn es einen relativ
kleinen teil dieser bevölkerung gibt der
sich beispielsweise eine impfung
verschließt oder über antwortet dass man
dann nicht dem individuellen
schutzbedürfnis denn auch die impfung
ist ja individual- schutz genau wie die
anderen schutzmaßnahmen und sagt den
leuten ihr müsst euch dann selbst
entscheiden ob ihr euch in einer anderen
stelle schützt das hat auch nichts damit
zu tun dass es sinnvoll sein kann bei
großen menschenansammlungen oder im
aufzug eines kaufhauses auch als fünfter
noch mal eine maske zu tragen aber es
würde dann eher in die eigene
verantwortung gehen wenn sie mich so
fragen glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
dass wir in deutschland in frieden
bekommen nicht weil er nicht machbar
wäre aber es scheint offensichtlich
keine politische mehrheit zu geben die
das tut und unabhängig davon sind wir
natürlich jetzt mitten im winter
insofern ist das rein von der aktuellen
infektionszahlen sicherlich nicht das
thema was ich primär auf drängt aber
dass grundsätzlich konstrukt dass man
irgendwann die eigenen fans an der
stelle wirken lässt und nicht mehr
staatlich verordnete das finde ich
unverändert ein konzept das man sich
überlegen sollte der kollege walter von
der badischen zeitung fragt wie bewerten
sie die aktuelle booster empfehlung der
sächsischen impfkommission vermerken
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
es ist wir haben unsere empfehlung
gegeben das habe ich jetzt schon
mehrfach und das ist ja mehrfach von
verschiedenen vorgetragen worden und wer
gibt es meinerseits dazu nicht zu sagen
gibt es jetzt noch offene fragen hätten
die weniger aber dann dazu passen dann
doch noch mal wann wird es äußerungen
von ihnen ich sage jetzt nicht
empfehlung sondern äußerungen von ihm
geben zu weiteren alterskohorten die
sich bewusst anlassen sollen auch kunden
sozusagen also wann kommt eine aussage
zu den 60 jährigen waren zu dem
50-jährigen bereich ich glaube nicht
dass es oder ich bin ziemlich sicher
dass es so nicht sein wird es gibt ja
zwei denkt möglichkeiten grundsätzlich
die man sich vorstellen kann die eine
denk möglichkeit dass man erweitert den
kreis der menschen mit vorerkrankungen
am sozusagen unter dem aspekt des
individual schutzes also denken sie an
unsere erste stufen priorisierung vom
dezember vergangenen jahres
und darauf kann man ja sehr leicht
zurück greifen und sagen die menschen
die da aufgeführt sind mit einem
erhöhten risiko für schwere erkannt die
soll man alle noch mit einbeziehen dass
wir einen denkt möglichkeit die zweite
möglichkeit ist dass man jetzt
unabhängig von der frage des individual
schutzes der überzeugung kommt ja wir
können einen signifikanten
epidemiologisch effekt im hinblick auf
die verminderung der wigos transmission
erreichen und dann würde man aber glaube
ich nicht mehr alters trat sich
vorstellen können sondern dann würde das
ganze
pauschale erfolgen das ist richtig aber
wie gesagt ich darf an dieser stelle
übrigens doch eins sagen weil es mir am
herzen liegt wir sollen natürlich auch
nicht mehr impfen bei uns und in anderen
ländern der westlichen welt als nötig
denn ich denke dass die forderung auch
der dritten welt die ja auch einen
anspruch auf impfstoff hat und und auch
die aussage der whu
nämlich dass man das beachten sollte das
möchte ich doch ganz gerne hier an der
stelle noch mal betonen und das ist eine
berechtigte forderung in der
internationalen solidarität dass wir
nicht sozusagen aus unserer situation
der stärke heraus jetzt so den impfstoff
wirklich ab sortieren vollständig wenn
es sozusagen nicht evidenzbasiert
infiziert ist also vielleicht sollten
sie das auch noch mal in ihrer
argumentation
in ihrer argumentation bedenken alle
dann hat die letzte frage herr gasser
man sie noch mal die frage ist es nicht
enttäuschen dass mehr als die hälfte der
niedergelassenen ärzte mit dem impfen
aufgehört hat weil es ist ja auch
kompliziert für die menschen die jetzt
möglicherweise ihren hausarzt wechseln
müssen um eine auffrischungsimpfung zu
bekommen nein das ist gar nicht so nicht
bestehen wir haben diese 75.000 da waren
eine menge facharztpraxen weil ich kann
es aus der eigenen praxis brechen wir
haben auch geben von haben auch viel
geimpft und das war damals auch gut und
sinnvoll weil sehr viele menschen das
bedürfnis nach impfungen hatten wir
haben jetzt durch die booster impfung
eine klar definierte korte die es
üblicherweise das sind ältere menschen
bei hausärzten in behandlung weil das
aber auch nicht alle sind sagen wir das
muss ein ein leitungssystem gehen wir
dann haben wir mehr als genug
anlaufstellen wo sich diese menschen
impfen lassen können insofern glaube ich
sind wir mit aktuell 30.000
perspektivisch werden dass mehr praxen
sehr gut aufgestellt das sind zigtausend
impfzentren über das ganze land
wohnortnah verteilt ich glaube dass eine
kommode situation hat kaum ein anderes
land der welt
ergänzend aus der sicht auch noch
betonen dass die zahlen zur zeit seit
ist die stiko empfehlungen gibt auch
deutlich ansteigen der praxen das heißt
die kolleginnen kollegen warten zu recht
auf die medizinischen empfehlungen
und steigen jetzt auch wieder ein das
heißt die zahl der praxen die impften im
zu und wir haben auf die bürokratischen
probleme hingewiesen das hat sich zum
beispiel der bestell zyklus für die
impfstoffe verändert verschlechtert aus
sicht der praxis komplizierter geworden
man muss zwei wochen im voraus bestellen
das heißt da sind wir dran
auch seitens der politik wieder
einzufordern dass sich die bedingungen
dort optimieren damit dass für die
praxen wieder einfacher wird und dann
sehe ich bin ich völlig auch bayern
passen das ist nicht in frage der zahl
der praxen wir werden ausreichend praxen
haben die das machen
dann schließe ich an diese
jetzt habe ich das mikrofon schon
ausgemacht und danke für ihr aller
kommen und dass sie uns hier auf dem
podium so lange und so läge rede und
antwort standen vielen dank dafür einen
schönen tag noch